c'était pmp way version arte avec de la
culture et ou à l'intérieur
j'en ai assez ressemblants regardez ce
que ça te regarde on regarde bonsoir à
tous et bienvenue sur arte reina touche
pas mais j'ai déjà merci les chéris vous
étiez 42 à nous regarder hier soir on a
battu notre record goût tout de suite se
sent belle émission à notre invité
joseph salvat directeur de l'opéra
transports j'adore à vous le savez c'est
mon bébé va y avoir de la cadart je le
sens en cas d'arcade jacques ada
c'est ça vous devinez qui est derrière
le rideau
alors d'après vous est-ce que c'est un
chevreuil qui se prend un doigt dans le
cul par philippe candeloro sergei pop à
l'offre loin dans ces révoltes
tchécoslovaquie et à la scala di luca
reste demain je le sais mais bébé à la
maison vous allez être comme des dingues
chaussée puisque c'est un vieil homme
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon bébé tu nous fait une petite
démo du spectacle c'est parti je ne sais
pas c'était complet on ressemble
maintenant toute la souffrance de son
peuple tout en gardant la grâce d'un
signal et usages d'agde
achetez-le souffrant d'un signe c'est
parti vous réagissez bons coups de
cutter les amis merci d'avoir été
arrêtées ou sur arte merci retrouve
demain n'oubliez pas la télé c'est que
de la merde